[Music]
v
johnny wants to ask you out on a date
what do you think
johnny's asking or is it you johnny
you're the one who said you got no
trouble telling us apart
okay and where'd we go where'd you want
to go
silver pixel cloud in north oak okay
i'll swing by the afterlife pick you up
[Applause]
so
some crew taking you along as bait
that a compliment you look
different try again
maybe you'll find some charms third time
around hey rogue
ready again you
we going where's joanie
couldn't make it after all
i'm just your driver see you keep them
on a short leash
wise beyond your years
johnny's push
where'd you get it that's what was in
the container the one grayson was
talking about
hmm okay got a lot of memories in this
car
let's go
silver pixel cloud your favorite place
once probably
haven't been there in ages drive-ins
went out of style a century ago
but silver pixels still hanging in there
sounds like a free place for a date
thought so too
which is why i suggested johnny taken
though a million years ago
though it wasn't his idea of course not
his idea of a romantic night out was
blowing up our osaka hq
all right v tell me what's going on for
real
johnny doesn't do a thing without an
ulterior motive
so what's in play this time johnny's
changed
he really does want to spend some time
with no hooks no lines
no sinkers
just taking it all in a selfless
johnny silver apparently you're a
positive influence on him
[Music]
[Applause]
show you better
here we are
[ __ ] i don't believe it it really has
been years
managed to shut the whole thing down
v try to get inside can't stop us won't
stop us
we asked you out on a date all right
do your thing can't stop us won't stop
playing bam
charlotte pass this all right all right
let's go
well done
try and get the projector started i'll
get us some seats
it's your thing
right let's go check the projector
entrance is over here
okay looks like i found the projector
you wouldn't happen to know how to get
it up and running
huh interesting bushido 10
fade to black must be a classic by now
to see look at that last played bushido
10
perfect looks like a spurt of runny [ __ ]
[Applause]
we're out of driving movies the last
thing we care about
just want some background noise a little
blood tits and gore
that sort of thing vegeta will give you
that
all right v run along i'll take it from
here
have fun you crazy kids
grabbed us the best spots
oh so that's how you do it
[Music]
i don't need this world anymore
but i need you johnny
i was wrong about you and it's a crying
shame that's how you imagined this
evening going
always knew things would have to change
for us to just go out and catch a movie
never imagined they'd change this much
[Music]
let's pretend it's 2015 huh we just met
and i got no idea what a bastard you are
[Music]
but i like 2077 rogue
a far inferior version
okay so it's 2015. if you could do it
all again
what would you change anything at all
i do everything in my power nozzles
hey what's this nothing it's just
had a lot of time to think while you
were away
what ifs and all that
i think you might be hiding something
from me
johnny there's a heap of things i'm
hiding from you
but all we gots this one night
it's more than i ever could have asked
for
rogue i'm here on borrowed time in a
borrowed body
but i'm here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
hmm
johnny i can't it's not right
mean it not fair to be not
fair to you tried so hard to pretend
nothing's changed
to pretend i'm the same rogue you knew
actually managed to fool myself for a
little
get back on my own rogue
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
rogue's gone yep
guess things did not go swimmingly
nope was gonna be a nice night at the
drive-in
now she's mad and won't tell me what
about
any guesses remember grayson how they
spoke
how weird it was words not the word i
don't think
he was toying with her could be
something to that
gotta mull it over for now take me to
north oak
that's supposed to help you figure out
rogue
no carrie tell you once we're there
movie was a turd wrapped in crepe paper